you
hi everyone is Jerry this is round 3
from the 2014 Sinquefield Cup between
the world's number 1 magnus carlsen
playing as white versus the world's
number 2 Fabiano Cara Juana
let's have a look Carlson opens with e4
Cara wanna reply z5 Bishop c4 the
bishops opening pointing at the weakest
Square in the black camp Knight f6 d3
and now c6 preparing to build an ideal
pawn center d v e5 structure Knight f3
development not with tempo in this case
this pawn is not being threatened since
Queen a5 would pick him up so blacks
consistent d5 it is and now Bishop b3 if
is white you are at all wondering should
I capture first on d5 and only after the
recapture do I back up notice that by
doing just that you will have helped
black the current ratio current pawn
ratio on the center is 2 to 2 if you're
the first capture and drop back it's now
converted into a 2 to 1 majority in
favor of black and you've vacated the c6
square the ideal deployment for the
Queen Knight so in other words after d5
it's best to immediately drop back and
do so knowing that there's not going to
be any problem after D takes e4 if black
is to follow up like that there's now
Knight g5 and we are again focused on
the weakest square f7 what would maybe
be best for black at this point is to
block with the bishop but after the
smoke clear is what we have is a good
ending for white perfect home on e2
better structure better Bishop since
this pawn is fixed on a dark square and
probably an accessible point to either
the white knight or bishop okay we don't
go down that road my point here is to
meet d5 with the media backing up to b3
as a follow-up we have Bishop b4 check
this move will inconvenience white in
some way regardless of how white replies
in the game it was c3 and then the
bishop drops back to defend a 5 now how
is white inconvenience by playing c3
well you can be sure the knight now
cannot make use of c3 and why would he
want to play there well white really
wants to put pressure on this ideal
black centre it's ideal it's strong
because it has options it's there else
to sit control a lot of squares like a
capture it could push white want some
clarification white wants black to
commit if the bishop initially plays
here there could be Knight c3 there's
pressure on d5 that's uncomfortable to
defend black may very well need to push
we now have a closed center and play
will ensue on the wings the white pieces
are quick to spring to life the F file
opens up you could see the Queen I'm
sorry the white rook and the bishop
converging on f7 soon the knight even
jumping into f5 ok but by inserting this
check c3 and only then dropping back it
will not be the knight who influences
the black centre what about another
option Knight here you don't want to
block the bishop what about bishop d2
that seems perfectly reasonable I
believe there is maybe some downside
with that as well notice after Bishop
takes Bishop Queen takes bishop this
Knight may very well increase these
potential may increase if he somehow
gets to f4 he's going to be a giant pest
it's not so easily kicked there's now
not a dark square bishop that can remove
them can a pawn guard f4 you bet with g3
but at the same time you'd weaken your
light squares f3 and h3 and do you have
a light square bishop around
and that is likely to be guarding those
squares no this is a queen side specific
bishop okay my main point here is that I
believe however you slice it light will
be inconvenienced in one way or another
by this bishop check ok the move chosen
with c3 the bishop drops back
this Knight will not be able to
influence the center but the dark square
bishop will Bishop g5 by applying
pressure to the knight he's now not
there to defend d5 it's at this point
that black commits D take C D take C and
now h6 okay white wants to keep the pin
Bishop h4 and now Queen to e7
reinforcing the e5 point the knight
wants to play here but that would be
dropping the bishop so its first Queenie
7 Knight B to d2 Knight B to d7 and now
Bishop g3 this move initially struck me
as a bit odd to pull the bishop off of
this diagonal to remove the pin in other
words but it's there to put direct
pressure on e5 and by doing so maybe
deterring black from trying some Knight
transfer to g6 that might be some idea
that black has but by keeping pressure
on e5 this is probably not a good choice
as an example let's say in this position
the bishop first backs up to c7 getting
out of potential threats on the D file
by the Queen or even the knight suppose
after this Bishop c7 move white castles
and now black tries to go for something
like Knight FA to g6 or something like
Knight f8 g5 and only then Knight to g6
looking to sink into the f4 square
notice how as soon as a move like this
is played due to the pressure on e5
there is this
tactic ship takes e5 Bishop takes Knight
takes black is there winning a piece but
only temporarily because now what
follows is Knight c4 hitting the Queen
and that Knight will be hopping into d6
with great effect soon thereafter Queen
h5 96 in fact immediately and the king
he 7 you get the idea black is running
for his life if Queen takes Queen
there's pawn takes Knight King takes
rook takes with check and at the end of
it
what do we have white in the driver's
seat white is winning getting the piece
back material plus as well okay we don't
go down that road my main point here is
that there is a reason that white has to
unpin the f6 Knight okay Bishop g3 it is
Bishop c7 again getting out of the line
of fire getting off of the only open
file white castles Knight h5 so with
this we're now going to have an
imbalance we're going to have a knight
for Bishop exchange the move played here
was h3 notice notice the what just
happened here this Bishop was the one
this dark square Bishop was the one that
eventually made that ideal center flinch
that's what made black commit having
pressure on d5 but notice now that that
Bishop is being targeted
he's now accessible if we compare the
bishops the darks the black bishops are
tucked away there's not going to be a
white knight attacking any of these two
bishops but clearly we have a black
knight that's able to take out one of
the white bishops the dark square bishop
in this case and create an imbalanced as
a result so while white was able to make
the black pawn center flinch
well now black is also able to pick up
the bishop pair and that's what we see
the move played here h3 is one that I
really have a difficult time
understanding I'm not quite sure why
that move was played I could see ideas
of maybe wanting to stop a bishop or a
knight from making use of this square
but to be perfectly honest I just don't
know why h3 was played here okay the
follow-up was Knight takes bishop pawn
takes Knight and now Knight to c5 let me
point out that these last couple moves
by white by playing h3 that weakens g3
and after Knight takes after pawn takes
g3 that also weakens g3 this pawn
occupies g3 but it does not control g3
and without the pawn on f2 you're no
longer controlling III so it's these two
key squares these two dark squares that
are now weakened
on the white King side and it is white
that does not have a dark square Bishop
around so immediately what comes to mind
is this dark square Bishop is there a
way to exploit the white King side
position okay so as a follow up what do
we have it is Knight c5 attacking the
bishop and the big shock of this game
was move 15 without a doubt Bishop takes
f7 wow there's a it's just out of
nowhere and see it was just quiet for a
little while here a lot of maneuvering a
lot of minor pieces getting involved and
black is not castled all of a sudden in
comes this Bishop takes f7 check well
there's only a couple options lets rule
out one of them immediately Queen takes
f7 will not end well
due to Knight takes e5 best is probably
to take the rook if you're doing
something else you are inviting the
Queen into the black position with check
and you're going to get killed very soon
okay let's not even go any further there
the alternative
to give up the Queen well that's not
going to turn out well seems like Black
has a lot of material for giving up the
Queen but this Queen is going to be
getting the bishop back white is winning
so my main point here is that after this
shocking move Bishop takes f7 you can't
take with the Queen it's not good so you
have to run right into a discovered
check or in this case a double check the
follow-up here was Knight takes e5 and
then the King has to run to g8 this was
not the only option another one was to
play Knight h4 and after King g8 get to
g6 this Knight eventually arrives on g6
the move plate in the game was Knight
takes pawn King g8 Knight g6 what are
the differences between this route and
this one here well for one the e5 pawn
is not around in this variation the one
chosen in the game there is no e5 pawn
around and what this means is that the
bishop will have something a bit more to
say about the White King side position
clearly hitting at g3 and directly
hitting at h2 okay this is the path that
white chose but maybe this was another
one to consider sure you don't win
material but you're at least not having
to worry as much about dark square
pressure the g3 and h2 squares okay well
in the game it was Knight takes e5
double check King g8 Knight g6 with the
fork Queen g5 staying very active
putting pressure on the dark squares
there's a checking square in e3g three
rookie fate king h7 and only move and
now there's a couple options here rook
takes rook Knight takes rook in the game
it was Knight takes rook if rook takes
rook the King has to come out of course
and only move is coming towards the
center but there's still a lot of tricks
in the position as an example while
there's pressure on g3 if let's say
white is trying to defend this point
here notice how this rook in the corner
is unprotected allowing for Bishop to g4
attacking the Queen
Black's going to be getting the rook
okay we don't go in that direction I'm
not saying that this is anywhere near
being a best move at this point but I
just wanted to highlight a particular
tactic in the position it's Bishop g4
idea which still shows up in the game
after the move played night tonight
takes rook in the corner eventually we
do see this bishop moving with tempo on
the Queen immediately in fact move 19
Bishop g4 is still played hitting the
Queen and this unprotected piece on f8 I
should maybe point out that after this
variation if instead of Queen f3 suppose
Queen c2 this is one idea to play Queen
to e3 I believe rook to b8 is another
idea simply defending allowing the
bishop to defend the rook so that this
Bishop is now able to move and we are
we're in a position here where it's the
two minor pieces versus a rook okay well
at the end of the day we don't go down
that road doing after rook check King h7
it's Knight takes rook so this white
knight is now in the corner as the
follow up it's Bishop g4 again Queen hit
rook hit Queen f1 is there now to defend
the rook and now Knight to d3 a move
that Carlsen later described as amazing
what is it doing well
a lot looking at the f2 square there's
ideas of queen III with Knight f2
there's also ideas of Bishop b6 getting
on this diagonal with check suppose
after Knight d3 white captures the rook
this is the main thing to consider can
white simply not win the black rook
what's wrong with that well what's wrong
with it is Queen III this is what black
has up their sleeve Queen III check if
King h2 this is running into a mate in
one - so let's not go to h2 in other
words what about King h1 King h1 allows
Knight F to check and what's maybe best
is to actually give up the Queen if
you're doing something else King here
this is running into a mate and three
with check check and then checkmate so
that's not working out so well and well
what other options are there
King G one runs into Knight takes e4
King H one Queen takes g3 and what are
you going to do to defend Queen here to
defend H two runs into Knight f2 and
then mate so really however you slice it
this Queen and Knight tandem and Bishop
being involved are just too much for the
white king and so in other words after
Knight d3 rook takes rook is not a good
idea the move played in the game Rose
Queen takes Knight and this now allows
rook takes rook pawn takes
and current body count here what do we
have black is down a minor piece needs
to get that night back but really
doesn't need to get that night back does
a right away the move played in the game
was Queen takes G for this night is not
going anywhere no need to take him he's
not bothering black it's very close to
the king but there's no coordination
it's just the night alone it's different
if there's another piece involved
another white piece involved in an
attack against the King not the case
here as a follow up we have Knight f3
repositioning the night trying to defend
the King side that is been wrecked here
on the white side after Knight f3 Queen
takes g3 again there's no need to take
the knight he's not bothering black
still moving forward removing g3 weakens
these dark squares and this King is all
the more vulnerable these moves bring to
mind the Bishop checks ideas of maybe if
you force the King to the h-file looking
for mate if the bishop can be
controlling g1 so we're not still second
move in a row r1 is not grabbing the
knight but grabbing another pawn more
vulnerable light King as a result be v
with
check so okay finally King takes night
is played be six this pond is looking to
start some trouble
clearly a couple steps away a seven
would come with tempo as a follow up we
have Bishop check king h1 King is just
barely hanging on this Knight is not
around to defend h4 Queen h4 is going to
be made with g1 being defended by the
bishop now there's very very very close
to black having some mating net against
the king so after king h1 its queen g4
which has the h5 Square now available
which would force the knight into
defensive post Knight h2 Queen d6 throws
a punch the rook black fires back
counterpunch
rook da Queen e5 rook d5 this rook is
very active I was just talking earlier
about queen h5 but now comes to mind
rook age 5
queen-to-be eight need to be direct both
players here these last handful of moves
have been punch counter punch King h7e
seven White's ready to promote queen h5
with check Knight h2 this was a big slip
by white there was a miscalculation
better is to play queen h2 and what
would follow is Queenie eight which is
very sneaky move of course looking to
track down this pawn and paves the way
for rook to h5 which is close to winning
that Queen a best move if this was the
move played right here by white to block
with the Queen on h2 after queenie 8 was
maybe best is g4 to defend the h5 square
but this is certainly weakening the
white king this diagonal the knight is
now without support black and grab that
pawn black is up upon better king
position and this is this is going to be
tough to defend I don't believe that
there is a defense if black plays
accurately here just too much heavy
pieces on the board to bish up too much
going for black in this line one other
line might have included rook to e1 but
that could be met with the bishop f2 and
if the rook leaves the back ranked like
rook here well the rook is going to come
down d1 you have to block like this and
then white is winning material and well
where else are you going to go with the
rook rook here allows for rook h5 and
the best that way I could do is give up
the Queen in the following way and this
here right this here is a very
interesting position there may very well
be some chances to organize a fortress
but keep in mind with this two two one
two one majority
lack is always able to create a passed
pawn maybe a G pawn or H pawn and maybe
one day the King could even sneak over
in this direction to put pressure on the
b-pawn and there could be a timely Queen
sacrifice of the B pond and then the
King could grab the white pawns over on
this side of the board on the Queen side
I'm just trying to give some idea of a
direction you could go if this was the
position and white is trying to hold or
build some fortress I played around with
this for a little bit and I had a
difficult time seeing exactly what the
correct method would be but I believe
that this is some idea to bring the pond
down to a 4-2 lock these ponds the rook
really doesn't want to leave the
second-ranked
maybe there's a way that this King could
somehow cross over here and put pressure
again on this B pond and there's a
timely Queen sacrifice on B to the rook
has to give itself up after black has
already let's say created a passed pond
over here on either the G or H files
this isn't a direction we went in but
nevertheless maybe a best-case scenario
for white if he is of course playing
rook to e1 at this point we never quite
got to this position in the game because
again after this Queen check on h5 it
was not Queen h2 but rather Knight h2
and what follows is simply rook d1 rook
takes Queen takes the knight has to
block Knight take era Queen takes Knight
King h2 Queen g1 check and it's at this
point that Carlsen resigns because what
are you going to do g3 h3 those are your
two options regardless of which one you
choose there's always Queen III and
Queen takes pawn black is up
peace upon better King materials the
biggest thing here white is clearly lost
in this position so I'm not sure what
was missed here after after the game
Carlsen referenced something like he had
seen this position a few moves further
back he said to himself he he had to
play this Queen to h2 because of this
rook idea but once it got to this
position right here he ended up changing
his mind and forgetting about this rook
to d1 move instead again playing Knight
h2 and he allows this first rank check
the knight is again picked up and after
queen g1 again it is at this point that
Carlsen resigned so that's all for this
video as always I hope you got something
out of it
take care bye Magnus replying e5 Knight
f3 knight c6 and d4 enters the Scotch
opening and now on move for black has a
decision opting for Bishop c5